on va accueillir à présent notre grand
témoin il est écrivain réalisateur il
avait signé une première enquête en 2016
sur la dictature invisible du numérique
qui s'est révélée visionnaire son nouvel
essai avec le journaliste
d'investigation Christophe Labbé va plus
loin l'homme sans contact aux éditions
de l'Observatoire décrit comment
l'intelligence artificielle nous
déshumanise jusqu'à prendre le contrôle
de nos vies Marc Dugain nous rejoint
juste après l'invitation signée ce soir
par Marion becquet
si on vous invite Marc Dugain c'est pour
votre nouvel essai sur la dictature du
numérique l'homme sans contact un homme
déshumanisé depuis le confinement un
homme qui travaille à distance comment
de tout en un clic se soignant visio
n'échange plus que sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est là où une société du futur
que vous dessinez avec le journaliste
d'investigation Christophe Labé vous
Marc Dugain vous êtes réalisateur
romancier aux multiples prix littéraires
6 ans après l'homme nu sur la dictature
du numérique vous récidivait avec
l'homme sans contact et vous analysions
apocalyptique qui n'est pas sans
rappeler le roman de George Orwell 1984
surveillance couvre-feu le roman semble
plus actuel que jamais
ce piège qui nous attend celui de
l'illusion de liberté de notre
déshumanisation de notre transformation
en consommateur addict vous le décrivez
avec précision nous aurons été les
apprentis sorciers d'un désastre pour
notre espèce la numérisation du monde
gouvernée par l'intelligence
artificielle dites-vous face à ce que
vous décrivez cette évolution qui semble
inexorable Marc Dugain est-il trop tard
pour un sursaut
bonsoir Marc Dugain et merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors
avant de répondre à cette question
est-il trop tard pour un sursaut quels
sont les solutions si on existe pour
mettre à distance un peu ce monstre
numérique on peut l'utiliser cette
expression va on va revenir au
diagnostic il y a 6 ans dans l'homme nu
vous allez retiriez contre cette
dictature invisible du numérique et 6
ans après L'Homme sans contact apparaît
alors sans mémoire programmée sous
surveillance et plus seul que jamais
c'est ça qu'on est devenu déjà
aujourd'hui d'une certaine façon mais
c'est vrai que quand on a fait le livre
il y a 6 ans c'est ça 2016
c'était c'est on ne savait pas du tout
qui allait y avoir la crise sanitaire et
la crise sanitaire a été un accélérateur
incroyable d'ailleurs une divine
surprise pour le patron de divine
opportunité la divine surprise c'était
les mots du président de Google
et c'est vrai que bon ça pour le coup on
l'avait pas vu arriver mais d'un seul
coup d'ailleurs on l'a vu dans la
valorisation des sociétés du numérique
d'un seul coup le le numérique était
déjà dans nos vies a fait une deuxième
entrée fracassante une accélération une
accélération considérable et aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que moi je me pose des
questions parce que je suis très
sensible à deux sujets qui sont le
climat et le numérique qui sont pour moi
les sujets d'avenir il est évident que
sur le climat on a pris 30 ans de retard
sur le numérique je pense qu'on est en
train de faire la même chose
c'est-à-dire que le numérique c'est une
technologie je suis pas du tout
technophobe moi je connais tous les
avantages du numérique et je les
reconnais c'est pas la question ce que
je crois c'est que le numérique est en
train et dans une vitesse et dans une
accélération qui n'a rien à voir avec le
temps politique
c'est à dire que les gens qui dirigent
les grandes sociétés numérique vont à
une vitesse qui n'est pas celle de nos
dirigeants et je pense que décennies
d'avance sur le temps politique d'une
certaine façon le pétrole a envahi nos
vies d'une façon très intéressante parce
que ça nous a donné beaucoup de confort
de mobilité beaucoup de choses très
positives aujourd'hui il est tellement
partout qu'on arrive aujourd'hui qu'on
arrive qu'on arrive plus à s'en dépêtrer
parce que c'est bien ça le problème et
je pense que pour le numérique ça va
être la même chose et moi je regrette
que dans une démocratie que la nôtre ou
en plus on a une constitution avec un
président qui est un peu au dessus de la
mêlée quand ce soit pas consacré et je
crois qu'Edouard Philippe d'ailleurs
l'avait reconnu en disant on sait pas
assez consacrés aux grandes questions de
long terme
au niveau européen on va on va en parler
le pire pour vous c'est l'intelligence
artificielle
[Musique]
euh et on l'a vu progressivement mais
avec retard c'est qu'une société de
surveillance est mise en place dont
aujourd'hui la Chine est le meilleur
exemple avec le Crédit social
c'est-à-dire que les gens sont
surveillés en permanence sont notés et
deviennent des citoyens totalement
contrôlés
aussi des scandales voilà comme bruit
d'analytica qui a montré que les données
personnelles de Facebook avait été
utilisé tout ça était établi et d'une
certaine façon le numérique nous nous
enferme dans un entre soi orienté vers
ce qu'on aime manger ce qu'on aime
acheter et ce qu'on aime penser
l'intelligence artificielle peut aller
au delà peut fabriquer quoi une forme de
d'humain augmentée plus fonctionnel déjà
déjà il y a beaucoup de projets que vous
connaissez certainement des des grands
du numérique sur l'homme l'homme
augmenté c'est à dire augmenter nos
capacités être capable de
discuter avec un anglais sans connaître
l'anglais mais en traduisant
simultanément il y a plein de choses qui
sont là encore très positive moi ce que
je crains c'est que l'intelligence
artificielle Vienne concurrencer l'être
humain tel qu'il est aujourd'hui c'est à
dire que c'est une forme de perfection
le l'intelligence artificielle donc à
partir du moment où vous faites des
robots qui sont déjà en pratique mais
que vous ajoutez une intelligence
artificielle qui sera de plus en plus
développés et et de plus en plus
perfectible avoir conscience d'elle-même
elle pourrait je suis persuade
de cette technologie là oui mais le
problème c'est que quand vous avez
quelqu'un comme Elon Musk qui est quand
même on peut le dire très leader dans
cette matière et qu'il dit que le
l'intelligence artificielle est
probablement le plus grand danger pour
l'homme dans les années qui viennent
vous partagez ça juste ça avec lui très
peu de choses métalliques
de ce point de vue là je pense qu'il a
il a parfaitement raison c'est à dire
qu'on va avoir et on le voit bien
aujourd'hui
si vous prenez un drone un drone peut
tuer sur un simple un simple ordre mais
est-ce qu'un jour il ne prendra pas
l'initiative par lui-même on ne le sait
pas donc tout ça alors bon j'exagère
évidemment parce que c'est pour les pour
les besoins de la démonstration mais je
pense que la question c'est la
conscience qu'on a d'une technologie qui
est une technologie très forte très
rapide très violente et qui a plein de
conséquences une des conséquences c'est
le fait que les grands du numérique
considèrent que l'État est une anomalie
on est avec des gens qui considèrent
déjà que tout que tous les politiques
même dans la politique c'est à dire la
démocratie directe tout ça on aura plus
besoin de tous ces gens là donc il y a
des mutations très très fortes qui se
mettent en place par exemple ça non plus
alors ça vous vous détestez d'abord je
déteste j'y crois pas trop
découverte de l'autre de l'Alt
[Musique]
est-ce qu'il y en a encore le fameux
sursaut c'est quoi c'est une forme
d'esprit critique vous citez Albert
Camus il faut savoir s'empêcher seul
soi-même vis-à-vis des gafas des géants
du numérique est-ce qu'il faut faire
confiance à nos politiques on est à
l'Assemblée il y a des lois à
différentes échelles comment comment
essayer de se prémunir contre ça oui je
crois que cette phrase d'ailleurs qui
est attribuée à cabus mais qui je crois
était du père de de Camus qui est une
phrase qui m'a inspirait énormément être
un homme c'est savoir s'empêcher et je
pense que le que le numérique c'est tout
savoir s'empêcher parce que le
en fait le numérique flat dans notre
cerveau des pulsions qui sont des
pulsions de consommateurs et qui ne sont
pas du tout des pulsions de citoyens
donc en fait c'est
consommer indéfiniment et vous n'avez
pas fini vous avez pas fini de consommer
quand vous propose déjà quelque chose
d'autre et ça je pense que c'est
vraiment
c'est cette société là qui m'inquiète
aussi c'est cette société de de
déshumanisation de l'esprit critique et
comment on fait pour l'activer pour
revenir à votre question moi
d'enfants qui ont démarré très tôt un de
mes fils en particulier avec numérique
qui ont été qui se sont submergés
numériques et qui a un moment on dit ça
suffit et donc qui reprennent les reines
donc là il y a toujours un espoir c'est
à dire que je pense que les les
générations futures vont se rendre
compte de la servissement à une
technologie dans lequel
des sociétés il y a pour terminer Marc
Dugain il y a un grand débat qui s'est
ouvert aux États-Unis sur la fermeture
de Facebook il existe ce débat même si
on voit bien les réalités d'aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il faudrait en arriver là
et moi je l'ai jamais eu mais je pense
ça serait pas une mauvaise idée merci
infiniment l'homme c'est-à-dire aux
éditions l'Observatoire et ses signets
avec avec le journaliste d'investigation
Christophe la